you're seeing this with people human
beings are innately creative and we all
hear about how moments of hardship or
moments of constriction and restriction
produce the greatest art because it is
the human will and spirit that's being
tested and the response to that is to
find a creative way forward and in this
moment where we're compelled to slow
down it helps us take stock of what's
truly important and the opportunity is
to realize the value of that and to
parse what is extraneous about our
fast-paced lives and make a more
conscious choice to double down and
invest in those things that are
important and to really avail yourself
of this moment to engage in that
creative spark you know dust off that
book you've been working on that never
seems to get the attention it deserves
or whatever pursued it is and invest in
that